One of the great things about reading
the Material Design specification
is that it is presented
using Material Design.
I was immediately struck
by the vivid use of color.
The spec says that color should be
unexpected and vibrant with bold
hues juxtaposed with muted environments,
deep shadows, and bright highlights.
To help designers, the developers of
Material Design provide a sample palette
of primary colors for
app developers to choose from.
Using these colors isn't some sort of
requirement, especially Especially if
your brand already has established
colors, but it's a great starting point.
Material uses the number 500 to
represent the base color for the theme.
500 is in approximately the middle
of the Material palette,
as in these examples.
You should pick a lighter version of
your color from the same palette in
the 100 range, and
a darker color in the 700 to 800 range.
I picked the 100 and 700 light blue for
the update to Sunshine, which is
similar to our original palette.
Then you'll want
the contrasting accent color.
To make things easier,
the Material palette definitions
mark accent colors with letter A.
You want to pick an accent
color that contrasts with and
harmonizes well with
your primary colors.
I chose a shade from the amber palette
because it harmonizes nicely and
matches our icon color.
After all, blue skies and
golden suns are not only friendly,
they are evocative of
our application name.
So, this is the final short color
palette for our application.
Using the support library,
we can easily alter our color
palette to use these new colors.